if a doctor is concerned that a patient
either has diabetes or is at risk from
diabetes they might suggest an a1c test
to be performed what i want to do in
this video is one just explore what a1c
even means and also how that actually
relates to diabetes or a high or the
main side effect of diabetes which is
having high blood sugar or hyper
glycemia so to do that let's think about
let's think about red blood cells and i
know what you're thinking what does this
have to do with diabetes and we'll get
there in a little bit so red blood cells
are the main oxygen carriers in our
blood they kind of look like these like
these lozenges
and inside of red blood cells you have
hundreds of millions of hemoglobin
molecules hemoglobin proteins
let me draw some hemoglobin proteins you
actually have the number i found is two
to three hundred million per
per red blood cell and then we have tens
of trillions of red blood cells so we
have a lot of hemoglobin in us and
hemoglobin is what makes red blood cells
red when hemoglobin is bound to oxygen
it has a red color so this right here
each of those are a hemoglobin protein
hemoglobin
now it turns out that hemoglobin let me
draw a bigger version of it hemoglobin
if it has some glucose around so let me
draw some glucose floating around near
the hemoglobin if it has some glucose
around there is some chance it's not a
high probability but there's some chance
if the hemoglobin and the glucose bump
into each other in just the right way
that they'll
they'll they'll
bind to each other and so you'll have
this situation where you have glucose
bound to the hemoglobin now this this
this hemoglobin with a glucose bound to
it is called glycated hemoglobin
gly
glycated
hemoglobin
i wrote glycated in green for because
i'm using green for the for the glucose
so glycated
hemoglobin
and another name for glycated hemoglobin
or hemoglobin that has some glucose
bound to it is hemoglobin a1c
hemoglobin
a
1c and now i can imagine things are
starting to click in your brain when you
are measuring your a1c levels that's a
test of the percentage of your
hemoglobin that is hemoglobin a1c so you
take a blood test they're measuring
relative to the total amount of
hemoglobin there how what percentage of
that is hemoglobin is hemoglobin a1c
and a normal range of that so if you
just have normal blood sugar over a
reasonable amount of time you're going
to have a hemoglobin a1c level in kind
of the four
four to six percent range
and people are still kind of trying to
uh tighten up these ranges and it
doesn't completely correlate tightly
with blood sugar well it does correlate
but there's still people with the same
blood sugar can still have fairly
different a1c levels but four to six
percent is considered normal
is considered normal and if you have
higher higher than seven or eight
percent so greater than seven to eight
percent so if you had like an a1c level
of nine or ten percent that's high
that's high and so you can imagine this
is kind of a proxy for how much glucose
you have in your bloodstream because the
more glucose you have in your
bloodstream the higher the probability
that that glucose is going to react with
the actual hemoglobin so that you're
going to have a higher percentage of
hemoglobin a1c and the other reason why
this is useful it's kind of
well i guess you could see on the on the
first pass it's useful because it's not
one of these snapshot tests everything
we've talked about so far with respect
to diabetes is taking your blood sugar
at any one point in time and we know
that your blood sugar changes throughout
the day it changes depending on how
active you are it changes depending on
what you might have just eaten so when
you take when you do blood sugar you're
just getting a sample you don't know
what the blood sugar is throughout the
day unless you just kept sampling it
which could get
a pretty annoying keep you know keep
pricking your needle with a1c
this starts to become a measure of how
much glucose you have in your blood over
a longer period of time and in general
it's kind of used as a measure for the
last few months because the red blood
cells and the hemoglobin in them
they have a lifespan of about 120 days
120 day
life span now that obviously doesn't
mean that all of your hemoglobin gets
produced on one day and then all dies
120 days later you have some red blood
cells and hemoglobin that might be a few
seconds old and then you have some that
might be approaching 120 days old so on
average they're going to be about 60
days old or about 2 months old so when
you're measuring this percentage you're
you're you're definitely not getting the
percentage of anything older than 120
days and on average you're seeing things
that are from about two months old so
the higher this percentage this is
saying wow things you know my average my
average hemoglobin molecule in my body
is only maybe 60 days old at this point
and already seven to eight percent of
them seven to eight percent of them have
already been glycated which is an
indicator that i probably have more
blood sugar than a normal person in a
normal situation only four to six
percent of of my of my hemoglobin would
get glycated so hopefully that explains
what a1c is
and uh but i i do want to say you know i
said at the beginning the video i'm not
a doctor and even if even amongst
doctors the a1c test or the a1c
measurement it's a little bit there it's
a there's there's some debate about how
useful it is uh whether what what it's
measuring or or kind of how far back it
actually is a good view at kind of your
your glucose levels and also as i
mentioned two people with the exact same
blood sugars could have different a1c
levels depending on
other things how old they are or whether
they have some other type of medical
condition